and went oh my god welcome to this video
hope playing I so-called yeahhh mister
sir colin just minus one currently am
I've made some progress I had absolutely
no score against him but I've gained
gain some ground just minus 1 now so we
get a get a beam only here maybe maybe
this move water prevent this castling
bishop age 6 stuff ok hmm trading this
definitely helps black mmm I can only
lie to do it it's very slow so i'm going
to agree to the trade him
yeah with the light squared Bishop
traded um black should be fine here I
teach five mmm yeah g4 is kind of normal
so I'll go for it Queen f6 that's the
idea 10 I think you know I think it also
wouldn't have worked okay so edition f1
normal move Queen B six though okay
could be six could be a jacket annoying
look cookie too yeah this is slightly
weakish the Queen side
you
so let's keep this all covered yeah I
guess that should be roughly equal maybe
I have a bit more space but not a big
deal night to e4 okay maybe this is
still setting him some problems I can
also i can gain more space here it
seemed left starts to stop nice for me
at least a little bit night cheeks he
has to check with the porn and this is
nice no c5 is a weakness 94 is a pretty
strong threat now I'm not sure yeah
maybe he has to do this 94 b 605
that looks like a problem for him he
cannot take now that's it's just a fled
win now black resigns yeah so i leveled
the score I was really having a really
big loss squad last couple of games I
got it under control he's a good
technical plant often swindled me in
losing positions so we had a Ben Oni and
probably Bishop e3 is not so precise
what I did here is um well there's this
line where check here black has also
check finally options here which I right
up his alley so I played Bishop e3 here
so that he M if you would have played
rupee aid that I had other options we
should be two for example we can still
second exchange yeah okay but Bishop f5
is good anyway so he wants to trade this
I think he's certainly okay and usually
if you get the light squared Bishop
traded and the Benoni you should be fine
night age 5 i'm not sure about because
this is a move that is helpful for me my
king side is not seriously weakened so
the a Bishop f4 now is natural looking
at this spawn check turn okay here I
could have played be three instead of
Ruby tune yeah the computer sees those
little things very easily okay that
would probably save a move yeah yeah
yeah I was losing time the structure is
nice for white but I could have
got Elizabeth more time or with less
moves invested computer still likes my
position a lot gives me more than half a
pawn I mean I am a bit better but I
didn't think it was all that all that
bad but now it got this is Sir leading
into needing to real problems yeah this
is the hoops the engine suggestion after
which I wasn't quite sure what to do g5
is a move just in terms of general setup
this is something that I welcome because
it's secures the e4 square so if you
imagine something like this 19 form here
he black a suffering in a somewhat worse
position this is probably probably very
very critical after that it's I think
it's losing Knight f6 is given by the
computer but at least this is possible
which is a real torture for black I have
easy ways to improve the position and
he's just completely passive yeah this
is this is losing losing the house okay
i'm happy that was a good controlled
game against the dangerous tactician
okay thanks for watching